okay let's go for uh another
five minute game against yon 606
uh don't know who that is obviously
so we're going to go e5 uh e45
and
we're going to go for the old relopez
trying trying to play relatively
classical chess
so far today at the very least
and obviously here there are
a lot of options for for black
ranging from more aggressive with b5 or
bishop c5 or knight e4
to more solid as as he plays with
bish b7 rookie 1
b5 yeah these lines have been
been discussed for um over a hundred
years
at the very least that's at the highest
level
now again number of options for
for black here my favorite for many
years
was knight b8 um
the knight bd7 the brayer system
also bishop b7
and then rookie 8 the sightsef system is
very
popular as well as knight a to a5 the
triggering system
they all have um different
advantages in drawbacks um yeah
this one i'm not
that sure about
rookie eight there there is a line where
you go knight
d7 but i think you usually wait for
knight b2
bd2 because here i get to develop the
knight to c3 and i think that should be
an advantage for for me usually
yeah usually in the rear lopes you you
develop the knight to to d2 that is
mostly because you're not allowed to put
the knight on c3
in in one go um
g6 is very reasonable um
preparing a possible bishop by fate and
bishop g7 rerouting that bishop and also
closing the diagonal of my bishop on c2
i think i may just take the
chance though to go bishop h6 in one go
and after bishop f8 um
i do feel as though the weakened dark
squares
may become a serious serious issue for
him
so i'm gonna go queen d2 develop
and now if um yeah if uh
knight c4 there was queen h6 also i
think after b4
there was knight d5 which should be
favorable for me
um now i do have a bit of a decision to
make though
e5 is tempting um
because of the tactic d5 uh
d5 bishop f3 i can take on f6 or
queen d8 and then take on f6 with check
taking
the bishop later on f3 winning winning a
full piece
um the question is if he goes for
something like knight h5 is that really
favorable to me
i don't know but it's it's kind of
tempting so we'll
we'll see probably d5 and then knight h5
is good
now that i think about it
yeah this was um
uh yeah this was probably probably not
not quite correct
but at least he's um he set some
some concrete uh challenges
um wow knight d5 is
actually a very nice move if
and this is a big if if he sees the
point
so knight d5 would look
like he's just winning a piece because
the knight on a5 is hanging
but he has this very nice intermediate
move knight c4
attacking attacking my queen um
after which he'll take back the knight
later on and
additionally he will um
he will get a very nice outpost for the
bishop on d5
as well as improving the knights on a5
which was on the edge
so i'm not really sure if that is
favorable for me
at all i do have other options like
b3 maybe um restricting the knight on
a5 or also bishop to e4
um i think i'm gonna
gonna play b3 um to
um probably keep as as much tension
as possible and try and induce
induce a mistake here for instance now i
think c5 which looks
very logical may be a huge mistake
because of knight e4
then if de5 i think knight c5 is good
and if cd4 knight d6 is very good
and his position will probably collapse
so it turns out since
he did not respond to this threat
probably
the moon knight d5 on the last move was
more
lucky than good sorry to say
and now um
[Music]
he will have bishop f3 somewhat ruining
my
my king side but
it is nowhere near enough and after
after 95 now i can meet queen g5 very
comfortably with bishop b4
and there are just no chances for him
bish b6 is a decent move but now bishop
e4 is
quite unpleasant
[Music]
i'm going to win i think even more
material
either either one more pawn as in this
instance
with the c7 hanging and now d4 is not
hanging because of queen takes f7
um or there were also in other lines the
pawn
a6 was hanging for instance if he moves
his his rook
and um now
again i think we have the old mopping up
job
queen e7 looks decent now if rookie 8 if
he keeps chasing i will go queen
queen c5 offering a queen trade
under i think quite favorable
circumstances
i as i would get a pass pawn and after
he moves this queen i can just
um yeah queen d4 is probably even better
knight c6 was also nice
um after queen g4 there should be a
decisive
sorry queen c7 there should be a
decisive
discovery check probably knight g4
it's reasonable this um now
he may not be mated immediately because
he has f6 but at the very least he loses
his queen and others making one
okay uh interesting interesting game
there um i think my opponent's play was
reasonable there um it was just one
tactic that was missed with which lost
him
she lost him tonight